there's no nothing in history that shows
us that what we're doing right now is
working like if you go back to greek
times yeah
here we go
um
where the men were really robust and
really uh
sculpted out right like this is you're
not talking about the greeks so we're
having sex with each other the guy
in the bath house is you're talking
about the man
so listen like so there was proof that
when our society started to
lose gender or that they would become
more like noodles that's like a quote
from camilla camilla paglia
glia and she's saying you can see it in
the artwork so you would see these
sculptures and then you would see the
guys there just like this like they were
becoming more feminine and that's when
the society collapsed
so that's why we're point right there
that's why what we're doing right now
we're repeating history but people don't
see it like that because we're used to
or we think about it and we're like oh
technology we see it through social
media we're not looking at artwork they
don't even have art certain art history
courses in universities it's like
they're trying to get rid of it that's a
really great point well the the the the
conflict right here is between innate
evolved gender roles like you were
saying a hunter-gatherer tribe's done
you know back on the sub-saharan african
savannah right
uh you know hundred gathering uh men
there was division of labor right that
men would go out and hunt that that's
what made them sexy that's why they're
built for combat that's why we you know
we go out and run down the gazelle or
the woolly mammoth or whatever and women
are back there because women are the
vulnerable sex and women are men are the
disposable sex meaning that we're going
to die more in in more greater attrition
rate for men is going to be a lot more
than there is for women we can look at
this and we can see the proof of this in
genomic records right now so if you go
back 8 000 years you'll find that one
man for every 17 women reproduced okay
we can we know this is a fact
old uncle genghis by the way one and
every you can go look this up too one
and one we did this just yesterday i
know one in every 200 men on planet
earth is a direct genetic descendant of
of genghis khan because he's just doing
his thing all right tyler before you
pull up genghis khan we'll go down the
whole history but what this is is this
is a conflict between
this this evolved innate uh
human nature versus the idea that we're
blank slates and that everything is a
social construct so when we talk about
gender when we i was saying before you
know is homosexuality biological or is
it a social construct because right now
we have according to the woke mob we
have 78 what are we up to now for
genders right now 62. so
gender identity and sexual orientation
that's what they totally let's see
that's what they that's that's that's
exactly what that's what that's exactly
what i'm saying here is that is that the
idea that that there's even that
division that there can't be anything
that's character fundamentally
biologically characteristically
masculine and feminine that's the
problem that we're having when uh matt
walsh went on dr phil not too long ago
and he was there with the bearded lady
the one who was the the the transgender
men who wanted to be women there oh i
love you he was having this conversation
with them and he asked one simple
question
what is a woman
define a woman and they would not define
it because they're stuck in the idea of
social constructionism everything's
relative everything's subjective it's
like whatever i feel like being today is
what it is the problem with that the
problem with that is that when it's a
life-or-death situation and men have to
be men and women have to be women that's
when this flies out the window we're
seeing that in transgender sports right
now so when guys go into the female
division of those sports like zoobee for
example holds the
world's record for power well here let's
let's i i just got uh noted thank you
for that everyone i just got word that
we're at two thousand listening
so we're gonna have to take a shot
in honor of the learning audience to
175.
here we go so 175 genders and tell your
friends tell your audi uh
people to join us okay don't forget to
take calls yeah yeah yeah we're gonna
take calls at the end let me just
let me just finish just really quickly
here the reason why that this was such a
controversial thing and why matt walsh
is still riding this right now is
because if that if the bearded lady had
said okay this is what a woman is
that's when he she it loses the argument
because now we can have an objective
definition of what a woman is and you
ain't it damn that's that
objective reality the whole conversation
changes
you